This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。欢迎收看“Look Back at It”播客。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的伙伴以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯主持的“Learn the Hardway”。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习“Learn the Hard Way”。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to the show. New listeners, old listeners. It is so great to have you here,
你好，欢迎回到“你二十岁的心理学”，这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时遭遇的一些重大生活改变与过渡，以及它们对我们二十岁意味着什么的播客。以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。新听友，老听友。很高兴你们来到这里，
and I'm so glad that you have tuned into this new episode that we're doing today. We are obviously talking about trauma. If you clicked on this episode, we are going to take a specific, we're going to make a specific focus on childhood trauma, traumatic events that may have occurred. when we were children. This has been a topic that has been requested by a lot of people,
我也非常高兴你能收听我们今天做的新一期节目。我们显然在谈论创伤。如果你点进了这一集，我们将做一个具体的探讨，我们将把重点放在童年创伤、可能在我们还是孩子时发生的创伤事件上。这一直是许多人要求的主题，
and I think for many good reasons, a lot of us will find throughout our lives that we do go through traumatic events, and especially when those events occur when we're children and our minds are really, really sensitive to our environment and different forms of distress or emotional events. It can have long-lasting impacts on our lives. So I'm really excited for this episode.
而且我认为出于许多充分的理由，我们许多人会在一生中发现自己确实经历了创伤事件，尤其是当这些事件发生在我们的童年时期，而我们的思想真的、真的很敏感于我们的环境以及各种形式的痛苦或情感事件时。它会对我们的生活产生持久的影响。所以我对这一集真的很兴奋。
I've done a lot of research. We will be taking a more clinical perspective than I think some of my usual episodes do tend to take. But before we do jump into the content, I just want to give a little bit of a disclaimer. Given the content of this episode, we will be mentioning instances of physical and sexual abuse, violence, substance abuse, self-harm and suicide. So if those are topics that impact you or that you find particularly triggering, just make sure that you are in, you know, a safe space and in a good, you know, a good place in your life to be able to listen to some of this content. And if it is triggering, make sure you reach out for support and assistance,
我做了很多研究。与我平时的节目相比，我们将采用更多的临床视角。但在我们深入内容之前，我只想做一个小小的免责声明。鉴于本集的内容，我们将提及身体虐待和性虐待、暴力、药物滥用、自残和自杀。因此，如果这些是影响你的主题，或者你发现它们特别容易触发你的情绪，请确保你身处一个安全的空间，并且在生活中的一个好状态下，能够倾听其中一些内容。如果它确实引发了你的情绪，请确保你寻求支持和帮助，
either from friends and family or from a local mental health professional or a crisis line. I do also just want to state, I'm not clinical professional. professional and you should seek clinical assistance or help if you require immediate support or assistance. I will leave some numbers in the description of this episode. I know that we have listeners from all over the world. So I'll try and make sure that there's a resource available for you in your country or state. Just to make sure that everyone, you know, some of the stuff we'll talk about can be triggering for some people. So making sure that you have the available supports. So today we're talking about trauma. Trauma is a massive topic to cover, which is why I really do want to take a focus on trauma that occurs when we're children. I think it's a really difficult thing to talk about. And most of us will experience some kind of event that creates shock and is emotionally overwhelming in our lives, but especially when we are children and everything around us is so new.
无论是来自朋友和家人，还是来自当地的心理健康专业人士或危机热线。我也只想声明，我不是临床专业人士。专业人士，如果你需要直接的支持或帮助，你应该寻求临床援助或帮助。我会在本集的简介中留下一些号码。我知道我们的听众来自世界各地。所以我将尽力确保在你的国家或州为你提供可用的资源。只是为了确保每个人，你知道的，我们谈论的一些东西可能会对某些人产生触发。所以请确保你有可用的支持。所以今天我们谈论的是创伤。创伤是一个需要涵盖的巨大主题，这就是为什么我真的很想把重点放在我们还是孩子时发生的创伤上。我认为这是一件很难谈论的事情。而且我们大多数人都会经历某种在我们的生活中产生震惊且在情感上难以承受的事件，特别是当我们的孩子和我们周围的一切都是如此崭新时。
and we are already in a state of needing extra support and feeling quite insecure, I think, because children often are dependent on others for support. Traumatic events can be particularly impactful. But the perspective that I really want to take in this episode is not a doom and gloom episode of, you know, there's no hope for the future, everyone's going to end up with some form of mental health condition. No, I really don't believe that. and the research doesn't support that either.
而且我们已经处于需要额外支持和感到相当不安全的状态中，我认为，因为孩子们往往依赖他人来支持。创伤事件可能会产生特别大的影响。但我在这集里真正想采取的视角不是那种末日和阴霾的视角，你知道的，对未来没有希望，每个人最终都会患上某种形式的精神健康状况。不，我真的不这么认为。而且研究也不支持这一点。
I really want to reinforce a sense of optimism and resilience in the face of these events, especially if the trauma that you've experienced was in childhood. And I saw this incredible quote that I hope summarizes what this episode will be focusing on today. As we know, trauma is the result of an overwhelming sense of danger, a sense of powerlessness, a sense of fear. But healing is a result of feeling safe and in. empowered and supported. So that is the direction that we are moving towards today, a sense of empowerment, a sense of safety, and a sense of understanding if this is something that you have
我真的很想在面对这些事件时强化一种乐观和韧性的感觉，特别是如果你经历过的创伤是在童年时期。我看到了这个令人难以置信的引言，我希望它能概括今天这一集将重点关注的内容。众所周知，创伤是压倒性的危险感、无力感、恐惧感的结果。但治愈是感到安全、有力量和受支持的结果。所以这就是我们今天前进的方向，一种赋权感、安全感，以及如果你经历过这种事情的一种理解感，
gone through, sometimes one of the best kind of assistance that you can be provided, or one of the best things for you is to really understand how that trauma has influenced you and to be able to recognize the impacts that it may have on your life to this date. So childhood trauma occurs when a child experiences or even observes negative events during childhood. And due to the impressions or shock of this event, the individual who witnesses or experiences this develops some type of psychological trauma or a response to the event and the impacts of that can be long-lasting. So today we are going to unpack childhood trauma in all of its forms, even those we often overlook, and that psychology as a discipline can often overlook, as well as some of the subtle ways that traumatic experiences in childhood
有时为你提供的最好的帮助之一，或者对你最好的事情之一，就是真正理解这种创伤是如何影响你的，并且能够认识到它可能对你至今的生活产生的影响。因此，当一个孩子在童年时期经历甚至观察到消极事件时，就会发生童年创伤。由于该事件的印象或震惊，目睹或经历该事件的个人会发展出某种类型的心理创伤或对该事件的反应，并且其影响可能是持久的。所以今天我们将以各种形式解开童年创伤，甚至是我们经常忽视的那些，以及作为一门学科的心理学常常会忽视的那些，还有童年时期的创伤经历如何以微妙的方式
continue to influence our mental health, our physical health, relationships, our values, self-esteem in unexpected ways. But I also want to stress before we begin, although we're going to cover quite a few theories and ideas about trauma, we do have less than an hour. we could speak about this topic for days on end. There are hours and hours worth of content on this topic because the research is so expansive and at times conflicting and controversial, which is kind of the psychology of trauma. So we are going to cover quite a bit and I'm hoping that you will learn something new. But there will be more resources in the description and I would encourage you to do more of your own research.
以意想不到的方式继续影响我们的心理健康、身体健康、人际关系、我们的价值观、自尊。但我也想在开始之前强调，尽管我们将涵盖相当多的关于创伤的理论和想法，但我们只有一个小时的时间。我们可以连续几天谈论这个主题。关于这个主题有成百上千个小时的内容，因为研究非常广泛，有时甚至是相互冲突和有争议的，这正是创伤心理学的一种体现。所以我们将涵盖相当多的内容，我希望你能学到一些新的东西。但简介中会有更多的资源，我鼓励你做更多的自主研究。
if you're listening to this episode from personal experience. I also think trauma is a term that in this day and age is thrown around quite casually. And although it's just a word, I think that it has become a lot more colloquial and part of our general speech. And I kind of want to dispel some of the misconceptions and generalizations that we collectively have about trauma and what it actually is. A lot of events can be perceived as traumatic for that individual. And trauma is absolutely a subjective experience. But sometimes we can use the term trauma and say that something traumatized us without actually knowing what that really means. And I think it's important that we kind of dispel some of the colloquial uses of the term trauma
如果你是从个人经历中听到这一集的。我也认为创伤这个词在当今时代被随随便便地到处抛出。虽然它只是一个词，但我认为它变得更加口语化，并成为我们日常说话的一部分。我希望能消除我们对创伤及其本质共同持有的一些误解和普遍化。许多事件都可以被个人视为是创伤性的。而创伤绝对是一种主观体验。但有时我们可能会使用“创伤”这个词，并说某事创伤了我们，却并不真正知道那到底意味着什么。我认为消除“创伤”一词的一些口语化用法是很重要的，
and have an understanding of what a traumatic event might actually do to you. there is also not a single truth when it comes to the different types of trauma and defining trauma, like many complex psychological experiences, especially those in childhood, where it's a lot harder to do research, you know, especially if it's with infants, they can't really talk or communicate. It's harder to get kids to participate in clinical studies. It can be really tricky to put our finger on exactly what the timeline for trauma is and how it might impact us depending on the age that we were when the event experiences, what was experienced, sorry,
并且对创伤事件实际上会对你产生什么影响有所了解。当涉及到不同类型的创伤和定义创伤时，也没有单一的真理，就像许多复杂的心理体验一样，尤其是童年时期的体验，那里的研究要困难得多，你知道的，特别是如果是婴儿的话，他们真的不会说话或交流。让孩子参与临床研究更难。要准确把握创伤的时间线是什么，以及根据我们经历事件时的年龄、经历了什么，它将如何影响我们，可能会非常棘手，抱歉，
but there are quite a few really great guides for this in the field of psychology. And one of them is the DSM, which is essentially the international Bible on mental health conditions and disorders that psychologists and psychiatrists use to understand people's behaviors. and the other one is this guide and this long-term study called the Adverse Childhood Experience Study. So those are the two kind of resources that I would send you towards if you were looking for a more concrete idea of trauma. So the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. So that is called the DSM. It's basically like a manual, a guidebook that clinicians use to consider and diagnose.
但在心理学领域，有很多非常好的指导。其中之一是DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册），它本质上是心理学家和精神病学家用来了解人们行为的关于心理健康状况和障碍的国际圣经。另一个是这个指南和一项名为“不良童年经历研究”的长期研究。因此，如果你正在寻找关于创伤的具体概念，这两个就是我会指引你了解的资源。也就是精神疾病诊断与统计手册。所以这就叫做DSM。它基本上就像一本手册，临床医生用来考虑和诊断的指南。
different mental health disorders it offers them some guidance so the DSM doesn't actually have a specific definition for trauma and that is a really important thing to kind of point out to people because this is the manual that allows clinicians all across the world to understand what people are experiencing give them a diagnosis and allow treatment to occur so the fact that the DSM doesn't actually have a definition of trauma and an idea of the different types of trauma is a little bit concerning. Instead, it tends to refer to the emotional and mental, physical and social reactions and impacts of trauma as PTSD.
不同的心理健康障碍，它为他们提供了一些指导，所以DSM实际上并没有对创伤的具体定义，这是一个非常重要的事情，向人们指出，因为这是允许世界各地的临床医生了解人们正在经历什么、给他们诊断并允许治疗发生的手册，所以DSM实际上没有创伤的定义以及不同类型创伤的概念，这有点令人担忧。相反，它倾向于将创伤的情感、精神、身体和社会的反应和影响称为PTSD。
Post-traumatic stress disorder, I'm sure that we have all heard this phrase before. And it's kind of an all-encompassing definition or diagnosis that covers and incorporates all types of trauma from different sources due to different events. And when we think about PTSD, we often think of veterans or people who have experienced war or, you know, traumatic accidents or violence, you know, a car accident, gun violence. And whilst these events and experiences can have a very significant and detrimental impact on us, the idea that trauma can only come from major events is one of the misconceptions that comes along with PTSD when in reality I think trauma can also emerge from things like childhood neglect and bullying and intergenerational trauma, built up events and so forth.
创伤后应激障碍，我相信我们都听过这个词。它是一种包罗万象的定义或诊断，涵盖并纳入了来自不同来源、由于不同事件的各种类型的创伤。当我们想到PTSD时，我们通常会想到退伍军人或经历过战争的人，或者，你知道的，创伤性事故或暴力，你知道的，车祸、枪支暴力。虽然这些事件和经历可以对我们产生非常显著和有害的影响，但创伤只能来自重大事件的想法是伴随PTSD的误解之一，而实际上我认为创伤也可以源于诸如童年忽视和欺凌以及代际创伤、累积事件等等。
In fact, in the DSM, to receive a diagnosis of PTSD, you must have experienced a traumatic event singular. This is called a stressor in the manual. And some of the options or guidelines they give are things like a natural disaster, an incident of violence, a life-threatening accident or a physically life-threatening situation. And then from there, they understand that your symptoms will fall into four main categories. So these are called intrusion, avoidance, cognition and mood, and physical reactivity. And we're going to discuss this later. But one of the caveats they give is that you must be experiencing these symptoms for at least a month. And they also must interfere with multiple areas of your life. You know, your work, you're still at school, your relationships, your home
事实上，在DSM中，要获得PTSD的诊断，你必须经历过单一的创伤事件。这在手册中被称为应激源。他们给出的某些选项或指南是诸如自然灾害、暴力事件、危及生命的事故或身体上危及生命的处境之类的事情。然后从那里，他们了解到你的症状将分为四个主要类别。所以这些被称为闯入、回避、认知和情绪，以及生理反应。我们稍后会讨论这一点。但他们给出的注意事项之一是，你必须经历这些症状至少一个月。而且它们还必须干扰你生活的多个领域。你知道的，你的工作，你还在上学，你的人际关系，你的家庭
life. And as we learn more about the complex nature of trauma, there have been a lot of discussions about whether that definition of trauma, that definition of PTSD is actually too specific and embodies an outdated kind of notion or idea of trauma, one that is based on physical events and physically traumatic experiences. And as psychologists have begun revising the DSM and their ideas of trauma, there have been some other disagreements or controversies as we kind of look further into it and we get a better understanding of how people might be impacted. And as well as that, the impact of childhood trauma compared to trauma that's experienced when you're a fully grown adult. You know, as they have started to revise it, one thing that they
生活。随着我们对创伤的复杂性质了解得更多，有很多讨论关于创伤的那个定义、PTSD的那个定义是否实际上太具体了，并且体现了一种过时的创伤观念或想法，一种基于身体事件和身体创伤经历的观念。随着心理学家开始修订DSM和他们对创伤的看法，随着我们进一步观察并更好地了解人们可能如何受到影响，出现了一些其他的分歧或争议。除此之外，与作为一个完全成年的成年人所经历的创伤相比，童年创伤的影响。你知道，随着他们开始修订它，有一件事他们
have noticed that the DSM doesn't actually have a good description of the different types of trauma. We know now that depending on the environment that you experience an event, the characteristics or origins of an event, that will really determine the impacts on you. And they're in a very similar vein, and we've kind of just spoken about this as well, but if you experience trauma in early childhood or even infancy, which we now know is quite common. the impact of that for you is going to be very, very different to someone who is 67, 68 and older who's experienced a car accident. And there's also that kind of line between trauma that is caused by accidents and trauma that is caused by those closest to you. We can kind of divide trauma
已经注意到DSM实际上没有对不同类型的创伤有很好的描述。我们现在知道，根据你经历事件的环境、事件的特征或起源，那将真正决定对你的影响。以非常相似的思路，我们刚刚也谈到了这一点，但如果你在幼儿时期甚至是婴儿时期就经历过创伤，我们现在知道这是相当常见的。这对你产生的影响将与一个经历过车祸的67岁、68岁及以上的老人非常、非常不同。还有由事故引起的创伤和由离你最近的人引起的创伤之间的那种界限。我们可以将创伤划分为
into those that are external and separate from you or external and close to you and then internal. We're going to go into that more a little bit later, but in terms of those discussions around whether PTSD is actually a good definition of trauma, there is hope and as a new language for describing trauma emerges, there have been better descriptions or definitions that have come about and also new categories of trauma, which is important for identifying certain symptoms and learn behaviors and reactions. And one of those new ways of describing trauma is the use of the term adverse childhood experiences. And this is where I really want to focus the episode on today, because we are talking about trauma that emerges during childhood. So adverse childhood experiences, these are
那些外在且与你分离的，或者外内在且离你很近的，然后是内在的。我们稍后会更深入地探讨这一点，但就关于PTSD是否实际上是创伤的好定义的讨论而言，是有希望的，随着描述创伤的新语言的出现，已经出现了更好的描述或定义，还有创伤的新类别，这对于识别某些症状和学习到的行为及反应很重要。描述创伤的新方法之一是使用“不良童年经历”这一术语。这也是我今天真正想把本集聚焦的地方，因为我们正在谈论的是在童年时期出现的创伤。所以不良童年经历，这些是
potentially traumatic events that occur in childhood. And there have been new. studies into the impacts and origins of adverse childhood experiences through the very acutely and smartly named ACE study that has been running in the US for a number of years. And it's focused on examining what exactly trauma can do to our lives and our psychology, not just in one period of our life, but from childhood to adulthood. So according to this study, there are 10 different types of childhood trauma across two categories. So personal and environmental. Trauma of the personal type includes emotional neglect, physical abuse, physical neglect, sexual abuse and verbal abuse, often from someone that we know or someone that we have a personal connection with.
发生在童年时期的潜在创伤事件。并且有新的研究通过在美国运行多年的、名字非常敏锐且聪明的ACE研究，对不良童年经历的影响和起源进行了研究。它专注于检验创伤究竟能对我们的生活和心理做些什么，不仅是在我们人生的某一个时期，而且是从童年到成年。根据这项研究，跨越两个类别共有10种不同类型的童年创伤。即个人和环境。个人类型的创伤包括情感忽视、身体虐待、身体忽视、性虐待和言语虐待，通常来自我们认识的人或与我们有个人联系的人。
Environmental trauma relates to other family members or things in our environment or our external environment. So this might include, you know, witnessing your parent really struggling with alcohol or living with a mentally ill family member witnessing domestic abuse or the absence of a parent following abandonment, death or divorce, and children, as we know, can also experience trauma in the form of a singular or major event, a long-term illness, the death of a loved one, witnessing a violent incident, a major accident or a natural disaster. So these types of traumas, those that we just listed, are called a major trauma. So I feel like that's kind of self-explanatory, major being large, being huge, being one-off.
环境类型的创伤与家庭其他成员或我们环境中的事物或我们的外部环境有关。所以这可能包括，你知道的，目睹你的父母与酒精作斗争或与精神病患者生活在一起，目睹家庭暴力，或者由于遗弃、死亡或离婚而导致的父母缺席，正如我们所知，孩子们也可以经历创伤，形式可以是单一或重大事件、长期疾病、亲人的死亡、目睹暴力事件、重大事故或自然灾害。所以这些类型的创伤，我们刚刚列出的那些，被称为重大创伤。所以我觉得这有点不言自明，重大意味着大、巨大、一次性的。
And in contrast to major traumas, we can also experience accumulating trauma, including chronic illness, being bullied, facing setbacks and poverty, housing or food insecurity. And importantly, these minor traumas, although they might not. not be really, you know, incredibly distressing in the moment the way that a car accident might be. They're just as important because they can accumulate and actually become major traumas over time. And often those minor traumas, I don't really like that name, but we'll continue to use it. Those minor traumas are overlooked. So many people experience, you know, bullying. So many people have experienced housing or food insecurity.
与重大创伤相比，我们还可以经历累积性创伤，包括慢性病、遭受欺凌、面临挫折和贫困、住房或食物不稳定。重要的是，这些微小创伤，虽然它们可能不。不会像车祸那样在当时让人感到非常痛苦、不可思议。它们同样重要，因为它们会累积并随着时间推移实际上变成重大创伤。而且通常那些微小的创伤，我其实不太喜欢那个名字，但我们会继续使用它。那些微小的创伤被忽视了。很多人经历过，你知道的，欺凌。很多人经历过住房或食物不稳定。
And, you know, it's not as, you know, interesting, I guess. It's not as novel as someone who has witnessed a natural disaster. It's so much more ubiquitous, which is kind of the terrible thing, because although it's overlooked, because it is so almost normalized and so common, it kind of raises the fact that there are so many people out there who will have experienced these minor traumas that will eventually accumulate and can become more adverse and severe than a major incident might actually. be. Trauma, as we know, can also occur across the lifespan. And the type of trauma that we might experience across the lifespan might differ. So it can include things like massive life transitions,
而且，你知道的，它没有那么，你知道的，有趣，我猜。它不像目睹自然灾害的人那样新奇。它是如此无处不在，这可以说是可怕的事情，因为尽管它被忽视了，但因为它几乎被正常化且如此普遍，它提出了这样一个事实：有那么多人在外面会经历这些最终会累积并变得比重大事件更具负面性和严重性的微小创伤。创伤，正如我们所知，也可以跨越整个生命周期发生。我们在整个生命周期中可能经历的创伤类型可能会有所不同。所以它可以包括诸如重大的生活过渡之类的事情，
vicarious trauma, which is a really significant one if you're a child. So vicarious trauma might, for example, include being repeatedly told stories or experiences of others who have gone through trauma witnessing someone else repeatedly go through trauma. For example, a parent who might be experiencing abuse or might be experiencing problems with addiction. And another huge one that has really emerged recently and I think deserves a lot more insight and a lot more research is intergenerational trauma. So intergenerational trauma refers to trauma that is passed down from a trauma survivor
替代性创伤，如果你是一个孩子，这是一个非常重要的创伤。所以替代性创伤可能，例如，包括被反复告知经历过创伤的其他人讲述的故事或经历，目睹其他人反复经历创伤。例如，一个可能正在经历虐待或可能正在经历成瘾问题的父母。另一个最近真正浮出水面并且我认为值得更多见解和更多研究的巨大问题是代际创伤。所以代际创伤指的是从创伤幸存者那里传下来的创伤
to their descendants. And it can also be referred to as multi-generational trauma. I think a good example of this. If you are in Australia, we have an amazing indigenous population, Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander people. And for many, many years, they suffered at the hands of white British colonizers who came in and separated children from their families,
传给他们的后代。它也可以被称为多代创伤。我认为这是一个很好的例子。如果你在澳大利亚，我们有一个了不起的原住民群体，即澳大利亚原住民和托雷斯海峡岛民。多年来，他们遭受了前来并将儿童与家人分离的白人英国殖民者的毒手，
in what's known as the Stolen Generation, murdered them, massacred them, and created destruction across their lives. And although the people today, the Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander people in Australia today, might not still be experiencing such extreme forms of racism and such extreme forms of violence, you know, many of their ancestors and their family members did experience that. And that trauma is passed down because it is so significant to, you know, their history. people experiencing intergenerational trauma experience trauma a little bit differently and their reactions and patterns or emotional and psychological effects
在被称为“偷走的一代”的事件中，杀害他们，大肆屠杀，并在他们的生活中造成破坏。尽管今天的澳大利亚原住民和托雷斯海峡岛民可能不再经历如此极端的种族主义和如此极端的暴力，你知道的，他们的许多祖先和家庭成员确实经历过。而这种创伤被传承了下来，因为它对，你知道的，他们的历史来说非常重要。经历代际创伤的人经历创伤的方式略有不同，他们对前几代人经历的创伤的反应和模式或情感与心理影响
from the trauma experienced previous generations is likely going to be a little bit different to if they experience that event themselves but different doesn't mean less, doesn't mean less significant, doesn't mean less important, doesn't mean less impactful. And in a very similar vein, a lot of research has now been done into this idea of collective trauma. So we have intergenerational trauma. That's trauma that is passed down. But collective trauma refers to a traumatic event that is shared by a group of people.
可能与他们自己经历该事件时略有不同，但不同并不意味着更少，并不意味着不太显著，并不意味着不太重要，并不意味着影响较小。以非常相似的思路，现在已经对集体创伤这个概念做了很多研究。所以我们有代际创伤。那是传承下来的创伤。但集体创伤指的是由一群人共享的创伤事件。
It may involve a small group like a family or it might involve an entire society. And traumatic events that can impact groups might include things like a plane crash or a natural disaster, a mass shooting. famine, war or a pandemic, which we all have been through. There are now discussions that the pandemic in itself could actually be classified as a form of collective trauma. So any situation, even a peaceful event that leaves you feeling overwhelmed and isolated and unsafe, can stress the mind and body. And if those feelings aren't resolved over time, they can become really debilitating and lead to poor decision making, addiction, depression, depression, low self-esteem and many other things.
它可能涉及一个小群体，比如一个家庭，或者它可能涉及整个社会。可能影响群体的创伤事件可能包括飞机失事或自然灾害、大规模枪击事件。饥荒、战争或大流行，我们都经历过。现在有讨论认为大流行本身实际上可以被归类为集体创伤的一种形式。因此，任何情况，甚至是让你感到不知所措、孤立和不安全的平静事件，都会使身心承受压力。如果这些感觉随着时间没有得到解决，它们可能会变得非常虚弱，并导致糟糕的决策、成瘾、抑郁、自卑和许多其他事情。
It's not just that traumatic events result in PTSD. And that's kind of the misconception I'd love to dispel, you know, if you have experienced a traumatic event, it's not just like you get a PTSD diagnosis, and that's going to explain everything. Okay, that was a fairly big list of different types of trauma. I'm sorry if that was very overwhelming. And sadly, we don't have time to talk about each of them
不仅仅是创伤事件会导致PTSD。这就是我想消除的误解，你知道，如果你经历过创伤事件，它不仅仅是你得到了PTSD诊断，而那将解释一切。好了，那是关于不同类型创伤的相当大的一个列表。如果这让人不知所措，我很抱歉。遗憾的是，我们没有时间与他们讨论每一个人
with the care and attention they need. But I think the main thing to take away from this is that trauma is highly nuanced and can occur as a result of many events, experiences, lifetime stresses, anything that you subjectively experience as deeply distressing or disturbing can result in trauma. And that's something that I really wanted to kind of involve you in, is that you are the kind of the best, you are the person who, who's in the best position to determine whether something that's happened to was traumatic or not. And in psychology, in this kind of field, we are not so great at identifying different types of trauma.
以他们需要的关怀和注意力。但我认为需要从中带走的主要事情是，创伤具有高度的细微差别，并且可以作为许多事件、经历、终生压力的结果而发生，任何你主观上经历为深深痛苦或令人不安的事情都可能导致创伤。这就是我真正想让你参与其中的事情，那就是你是最好的，你是那个，处于最好位置来确定发生在身上的事情是否具有创伤性的人。在心理学中，在这个领域中，我们并不善于识别不同类型的创伤。
And sometimes that can mean that, you know, minor traumas can be dismissed or traumas that don't fit into a very distinct box can be dismissed. But that's something we want to dispel anything that causes you distress can be a traumatic event. But what I do want to focus on is childhood trauma, especially trauma that is associated. with emotional neglect that occurs within some of our most precious environments, and that is our family units and our relationships with our caregivers. Children need stable, sensitive, loving, stimulating relationships and environments in order to reach their potential.
有时这意味着，你知道的，微小的创伤可能会被忽视，或者不适合非常明确的盒子的创伤可能会被忽视。但这正是我们想要消除的，任何引起你痛苦的事情都可以是一个创伤事件。但我想关注的是童年创伤，尤其是与情感忽视相关的创伤，它发生在我们最珍贵的环境中，也就是我们的家庭单位和我们与照顾者的关系中。孩子们需要稳定、敏感、充满爱心、刺激的关系和环境，才能发挥他们的潜力。
That is why experiences of neglect and abuse at the hands of those who are meant to care for us, who we expect to look after us, can be, particularly distressing and harmful for infants, for children, for teenagers. And given that our primary drive when we are babies and when we are children is towards attachment, often what will happen is we will accommodate the environments that we are in and we will accommodate the things that our parents do to us because at the end of the day, what we need as children is attachment. We need to feel connected to someone for a sense of safety.
这就是为什么遭受本应照顾我们、我们期望照顾我们的人的忽视和虐待，对于婴儿、儿童、青少年来说，可能是特别痛苦和有害的。鉴于我们作为婴儿和儿童时的主要驱动力是依恋，通常会发生的是我们将适应我们所处的环境，我们将适应我们的父母对我们做的事情，因为归根结底，我们作为孩子所需要的是依恋。我们需要为了安全感而与某人建立联系。
And obviously as a child, you don't really have much choice given our age and vulnerability and in more chronic and extreme circumstances. Because we are driven towards that attachment, especially with our caregivers, and if we are experiencing neglect and abuse in those situations, we can end up forming and showing a really complex trauma response. And eventually, if you are a child who has experienced one of those personal traumas that we were talking about, you know, seeing a parent who's struggling with addiction, seeing divorce, seeing, you know, experiencing the death of a parent, we might eventually make meaning of that circumstance by
显然，作为一个孩子，鉴于我们的年龄和脆弱性，在更长期和极端的环境中，你其实并没有太多选择。因为我们被驱使去建立那种依恋，尤其是与我们的照顾者，如果我们正在那些情况下经历忽视和虐待，我们最终可能会形成并表现出非常复杂的创伤反应。最终，如果你是一个经历过我们一直在谈论的那些个人创伤之一的孩子，你知道的，看到一个正在与成瘾作斗争的父母，看到离婚，看到，你知道的，经历父母的死亡，我们最终可能会通过以下方式理解这种环境：
believing that it's our fault and that we are inherently bad and, you know, blaming ourselves. You know, as children, our brains are really, really malleable. We are, we don't have much experience as to what is normal. So we will adapt to frightening and overwhelming circumstances through the body's survival response whereby our autonomic nervous system takes control. So this is the part of our nervous system that kind of just switches on immediately. We don't really have a say. And this will become activated and switch on to freeze flight or flight response.
相信这是我们的错，我们本质上是坏的，你知道的，责怪自己。你知道，作为孩子，我们的大脑真的、真的很具可塑性。我们，我们对于什么是正常的没有什么经验。因此，我们将通过身体的生存反应来适应可怕和压倒性的环境，在这种反应中，我们的自主神经系统控制了局面。所以这是我们神经系统的这一部分，它基本上立即开启。我们其实没有发言权。这将变得活跃并开启，以冻结、逃跑或战斗反应。
We've talked about this before. Basically, when our brains and our bodies are sensing danger, are sensing something traumatic, a sensing, a sensing something that could put us at risk. Our body is flooded with all of these chemicals, including adrenaline and cortisol, that in a normal situation, if the danger is one that is incredibly life-threatening, will allow us to, you know, fight back
我们以前谈过这个。基本上，当我们的大脑和身体感觉到危险时，感觉到有创伤性的事情，感觉到可能让我们处于风险之中的事情。我们的身体被所有这些化学物质淹没，包括肾上腺素和皮质醇，在正常情况下，如果危险是非常危及生命的，将允许我们，你知道的，反击
or allow us to run faster and run away from that event. But if you're a child and you don't really have that capacity and, you know, you're reliant on your, you know, your parental environment and your home environment for safety and shelter, instead of having the opportunity to flee or to fight back, we end up feeling quite agitated and hypervigilant and powerless. Infants might also show a really different response. If they are experiencing some form of neglect or if they're experiencing a traumatic event,
或者允许我们跑得更快并逃离该事件。但如果你是一个孩子，你真的没有那种能力，并且，你知道的，你依赖你的，你知道的，父母环境和你的家庭环境来获得安全和庇护，而不是有机会逃跑或反击，我们最终会感到相当激动、高度警惕和无力。婴儿也可能表现出非常不同的反应。如果他们正在经历某种形式的忽视，或者如果他们正在经历创伤事件，
they might show a frozen watchfulness and can almost appear to be zoned out. And children and young people also have that experience of dissociating. You know, if your parents are going through a divorce or you've sadly lost a parent, it's really difficult to be exposed to that situation and not have some kind of safety mechanism to get you through. And sometimes those mechanisms or coping mechanisms that our body uses to get us through those really, really hard events are ones that aren't in our control. And that can include completely dissociating and tapping out of a, of a very, of a very hard event. an event that's happening as a way of protecting ourselves. And prolonged exposure to events or a situation where trauma is occurring can actually lead to toxic stress. And that really
他们可能会表现出一种冻结的警觉性，几乎显得魂不守舍。儿童和年轻人也有解离的经历。你知道的，如果你的父母正在经历离婚，或者你不幸失去了父母，要暴露在那种情况下却没有某种安全机制来度过难关，那是真的很困难。有时，我们的身体用来帮助我们度过那些非常、非常艰难的事件的机制或应对机制是我们无法控制的。这可能包括完全解离并脱离一个，一个非常，非常艰难的事件。一个正在发生的事件，作为保护我们自己的一种方式。而长期接触事件或正在发生创伤的情况实际上会导致有毒的应激。这确实
changes the development and the brain development of a child. It sensitizes the child to further stress. It leads to heightened activity levels and affects future learning and concentration. And most importantly, it can really impair a child's ability to trust and relate to others as they grow up. when a child is traumatized, they might find it really hard to regulate their behaviors. And like I said, trust people and as they grow up and they develop into adults, other areas of their lives might be acutely impacted. And in really important areas, things that are really crucial to our well-being, like our ability to be vulnerable, our ability to connect,
改变了一个孩子的发展和大脑发育。它使孩子对进一步的应激更加敏感。它会导致高度活跃的水平，并影响未来的学习和集中注意力。最重要的是，它确实会损害孩子在成长过程中信任他人和与他人建立联系的能力。当一个孩子受到创伤时，他们可能会发现很难调节他们的行为。就像我说的，信任别人，随着他们的成长并发展成成年人，他们生活的其他领域可能会受到严重影响。在真正重要的领域，那些对我们的幸福至关重要的领域，比如我们脆弱的能力，我们联系的能力，
our ability to monitor our emotions and, you know, feel the right level of arousal, feel the right level of excitement and happiness versus sadness and distress. So what are some of the lasting impacts on our bodies, on our brains and of our lives if we do experience a traumatic event in childhood? So there is a lot of research about this. We are going to talk about some of the kind of negative side effects, but take it with a grain of salt. We're going to talk a little bit later about how this won't be the case for everyone, but research has suggested that the type of trauma that occurs during childhood in particular can leave pretty deep marks, giving rise to issues like depression, anxiety and substance abuse.
我们监控情绪的能力，你知道的，感受到正确水平的唤醒，感受到正确水平的兴奋和快乐与悲伤和痛苦。那么，如果我们确实在童年时期经历了创伤事件，对我们的身体、大脑和生活有哪些持久的影响呢？所以有很多关于这方面的研究。我们将讨论一些消极的副作用，但请持保留态度。我们稍后会讨论为什么这不会适用于每个人，但研究表明，尤其是在童年时期发生的创伤类型，可以留下相当深的印记，引发抑郁、焦虑和药物滥用等问题。
As we know, particularly with substance abuse, it doesn't discriminate people from all walks of life have struggled with addiction. However, those who have experienced trauma are far more likely to abuse drugs like alcohol, like opioids, like painkillers, anything of the sort, because they may be using them to self-medicate and to escape the pain they may be feeling. We talked about this before, but children don't have as much agency in traumatic situations.
众所周知，特别是在药物滥用方面，它并不歧视来自各行各业的人都在与成瘾作斗争。然而，那些经历过创伤的人更有可能滥用诸如酒精、阿片类药物、止痛药之类的药物，任何类似的东西，因为他们可能在用它们来进行自我药疗并逃避他们可能感受到的痛苦。我们以前谈过这个，但在创伤情况下，儿童没有那么多的能动性。
And so one of the ways that they avoid experiencing the full shock of an event is by disassociating, is by compartmentalizing the emotions that they would like to feel. And their brain kind of says, you know, we don't have the capacity to feel this right now. Let's put it in a box and we'll think about it later. But if that later never comes, what ends up happening is those emotions that have been stored away kind of bubble to the surface.
因此，他们避免经历事件的全部冲击的方式之一就是解离，就是把他们想要感受的情绪进行区隔化。他们的大脑有点像在说，你知道的，我们现在没有能力感受这个。把它放在盒子里，我们以后再想。但如果那个后来永远不会到来，最终发生的事情是，那些被储藏起来的情绪有点像浮出水面。
And that's where things like substance abuse might occur because it's a really great kind of soother for our brain. Of course, the long-term impacts of that might actually end up making our trauma worse. And alongside, you know, a greater likelihood of developing depression and anxiety, there's also a very strong link between trauma and disassociation. Ongoing trauma, especially childhood, physical, sexual or emotional abuse or neglect, is a very significant risk factor for the development of dissociative disorders. And it's actually thought that about 90% of people who end up being diagnosed with some form of dissociative disorder
这就是为什么可能会发生诸如药物滥用之类的事情，因为这对我们的大脑来说是一个非常好的抚慰剂。当然，这带来的长期影响实际上可能会使我们的创伤恶化。伴随着患抑郁和焦虑的更高可能性，创伤和解离之间也存在着非常紧密的联系。持续的创伤，尤其是童年的身体、性或情感虐待或忽视，是发展为解离性障碍的一个非常显著的风险因素。据认为，大约90%最终被诊断出患有某种形式的解离性障碍的人
did have trauma in their childhood that is related to this diagnosis. So dissociation like we've talked about, it's basically a natural mechanism your body uses to help you survive trauma. So it's an escape. It's an involuntary detachment from reality, often experienced as a disconnect from your sense of self, your thoughts, and your memory. So when human beings are psychologically overwhelmed, we seek safety. Sometimes that safety that we crave cannot be met at that time by our external world. So instead, we seek safety internally. The outside world isn't within our control, but our inner world is.
在他们的童年时期确实经历过与该诊断相关的创伤。所以就像我们谈到的解离，它基本上是你身体用来帮助你在创伤中生存的自然机制。所以它是一种逃避。它是与现实的不由自主的脱离，通常表现为与你的自我感、你的想法和你的记忆的脱离。因此，当人类在心理上不堪重负时，我们寻求安全。有时我们渴望的安全在那时无法通过我们的外部世界来满足。相反，我们在内部寻求安全。外部世界不在我们的掌控之中，但我们的内心世界是。
So we detach from our emotions, we push them aside. But sometimes that dissociation, which is a coping mechanism, which allows us to survive, it's important. Our brain does it naturally for a reason. It can keep going long after that traumatic event might actually be occurring. And the result of that can be things like memory loss, an amnesia of certain, periods of our life, certain personal information, we can have a prolonged sense of being detached from ourselves and detached from our emotions, a blurred sense of identity and significant stress or problems in your relationships and your work life, and an inability to cope. And that makes sense.
所以我们从我们的情绪中脱离出来，把它们放在一边。但有时那种解离，作为一种应对机制，它允许我们生存，这是很重要的。我们的大脑自然会这样做是有原因的。在那个创伤事件实际发生很久之后，它仍然可以继续。其结果可能是记忆丧失，对某些特定时期的健忘，某些个人信息，我们可能会有一种长期的与自己脱离、与情绪脱离的感觉，模糊的身份感以及在你的关系和工作生活中出现严重的压力或问题，以及无力应对。这是有道理的。
You know, you've had something really terrible happen to you, something that is almost split your brain and caused your brain to undergo significant stress. So if that isn't resolved, if that isn't something that you get help for, you know, in the immediate aftermath of an event, it can cause long-term problems. There's also problems with self-esteem. You know, if you've experienced trauma in childhood of all types, you know, you've had a chronic illness, your parents have gotten divorced, you've experienced a death or a traumatic event, an accident. Sometimes the only way that our young minds can justify that,
你知道，你经历了一些非常糟糕的事情，有些几乎分裂了你的大脑，并使你的大脑承受了巨大的压力。所以如果不去解决这个问题，如果没有在事件发生后立即寻求帮助，你知道的，这可能会导致长期的严重问题。同时也会产生自尊心的问题。你知道的，如果你在童年时期经历过各种类型的创伤，比如你曾患有慢性病，你的父母离婚了，你经历了一次死亡或创伤性事件、一场事故。有时我们年轻的大脑唯一能将之合理化的方式，
and the only explanation we can give is that it had something to do with, you. You know, if you've experienced abuse, I think something that therapists often hear is like, how is it my fault? It's really hard to explain things like that. It's really, really difficult, especially if you are a child or you're an infant. And as a result, as we get older, we might see it as a consequence of who we are and our self-esteem can really plummet. It also impacts our relationship, especially traumatic events that occur in that beautiful space and that beautiful precious environment between a child and a caregiver, if something isn't quite right there, if you've experienced abuse or neglect or even a feeling of being ignored or abandoned, that's going to impact
我们能给出的唯一解释就是这与你有关。你知道的，如果你经历过虐待，我想治疗师经常听到的一句话是：“这怎么会是我的错？”要解释这样的事情真的很困难。这真的非常非常难，特别是如果你当时还是个孩子或婴儿。因此，随着年龄的增长，我们可能会将其视为我们自身的一种后果，从而导致我们的自尊心一落千丈。它还会影响我们的关系，尤其是发生在儿童与照顾者之间那段美好的空间和那段美好珍贵的环境中的创伤性事件，如果那里有些事情不太对劲，如果你经历过虐待、忽视，甚至是感到被忽视或被抛弃，这将会影响
your attachment styles in the future. We did a whole episode on this. But things like anxious attachment style or avoidant attachment styles are really common after people have gone through a traumatic childhood event. And it's really difficult to connect with others. especially in an intimate way if you've been taught by your past experiences that those who are meant to love you will inevitably harm you or abandon you. Another thing that I really want to discuss that I think isn't talked about often is the impact to our brain structures and our behavior. So there is heaps of evidence that social and emotional information is processed really differently among children that have experienced abuse or some kind of trauma versus those who have not.
你未来的依恋风格。我们为此做过一整期节目。但像焦虑型依恋风格或回避型依恋风格，在人们经历了童年的创伤事件后是非常普遍的。并且很难与他人建立联系，特别是如果你过去的经验让你明白那些本该爱你的人最终一定会伤害你或抛弃你，那么你就很难进行亲密接触。另一件我非常想讨论、而我认为人们往往讨论得不够的事情，就是对我们大脑结构和行为的影响。因此，有大量的证据表明，在经历过虐待或某种创伤的儿童与没有经历过这些的儿童之间，他们处理社会和情感信息的方式有很大的不同。
So the amygdala, this is an area of our brain that's responsible for processing fear and emotional information, has been shown to be really over-responsive to emotional stimuli, things like angry faces, loud noises in children who have experienced neglect or abuse. So traumatized children, they're often able to identify angry faces a lot more. quicker than non-traumatized children. They're a lot more responsive to loud noises. They're a lot more responsive to, you know, indicators that someone might be abandoning them or indicators of something being wrong in their environment compared to children who are non-traumatized. And that kind of suggests that their brain has now primed them to detect a threat. If your early learning experiences
所以杏仁核，这是我们大脑中负责处理恐惧和情感信息的区域，研究表明它对情感刺激（比如愤怒的面孔、巨大的噪音）过度敏感，这在经历过忽视或虐待的儿童身上表现得尤为明显。因此，受过创伤的儿童，他们通常能够比未受过创伤的儿童更快地识别出愤怒的面孔。他们对巨响的反应要强烈得多。他们对那些暗示某人可能会抛弃他们或者暗示他们环境中出现问题的迹象反应更加敏感，相比之下，那些没有受过创伤的孩子则不然。这在某种程度上表明，他们的大脑现在已经做好了随时检测威胁的准备。如果你早期的学习经验
are based on a sense of fear, you know, you've been taught that the world is a dangerous place, that you might be harmed. Our brains adapt to that. We want to be able to take that information in and learn from it. And there's also been studies showing that our memory gets impaired in some ways that our brain can actually develop in abnormal ways or develop in ways that, yeah, that can be really detrimental to our memory and to how we process emotions. So people who have undergone abuse as children,
是建立在恐惧感之上的，你知道的，你被灌输的概念是世界是个危险的地方，你可能会受到伤害。我们的大脑会适应这种环境。我们希望能够吸收这些信息并从中吸取教训。此外，还有研究表明，我们的记忆力会在某些方面受损，我们的大脑实际上会以不正常的方式发育，或者以某种确实会对我们的记忆力和情感处理方式产生极大负面的方式发育。所以，那些在儿童时期遭受过虐待的人，
you know, it might seem that they have it worse off. That's something that I want to dispel in this next kind of segment of the episode. And look, you know, I've talked about a lot of the negative side effects. And I did think maybe we could talk about the benefits, the benefits of trauma. I think that is a terrible way of putting it. And you can do your own research into that because I really, really hate that sense of, you know, your trauma made you stronger or you had to go through that to be the person you are today. You know, everything in life is a learning experience and changes how we
你知道的，看起来他们情况更糟糕。这是我在接下来的节目中想要消除的一种观点。而且，你知道的，我已经谈了很多负面影响。我原本在想，也许我们可以谈谈好处，谈谈创伤带来的好处。我觉得这样表达真是太糟糕了。你们可以自己去研究一下这个问题，因为我真的非常非常讨厌那种“你的创伤让你变得更坚强”或者“你必须经历那些才能成为今天的你”的说法。你知道的，生活中的一切都是学习经历，都会改变我们
interpret our environment. You don't need to experience trauma to become resilient and an emotionally intelligent human being, nor should you have to. You know, I don't think that we should have this discussion around trauma being something that's positive or something that's like a blessing, like, oh, you know, if you hadn't gone through that, you wouldn't be where you are today. You wouldn't be so resilient. You know, you could have been just as resilient. without going through that. So I do really kind of resent this idea that trauma is in some ways or, you know, abuse or neglect is in some ways a good thing. So you do want to look into some of those benefits. I really don't like saying that. But, you know, some of the upsides of trauma,
对环境的解读方式。你不需要经历创伤就能变得坚韧并成为一个情商高的人，你也不应该被迫去经历这些。你知道的，我不认为我们应该把创伤讨论成一件积极的事情，或者像是一种祝福，比如，“哦，你知道的，如果你没有经历过那个，你也不会有今天的成就。你不会这么坚韧。”要知道，你本来也可以同样坚韧，而不必经历那些痛苦。所以我真的很反感这种认为创伤在某种程度上——或者虐待、忽视在某种程度上是一件好事的想法。所以你确实会想要去了解一些所谓的好处。我真的不喜欢这么说。但是，你知道的，创伤的一些积极面，
if you would like to look into that, I do ask that you do your own research. I just don't think it's a positive thing to talk about here. But we do know anecdotally and clinically that many people can overcome childhood trauma and not experience some of those impacts that we've talked about. There are so many people who have experienced neglect or abuse or divorced or death or an accident who don't go on to experience addiction, who live really amazing lives. And after experiencing trauma, we do know that some people tend to have better outcomes in adulthood compared to others. And psychologists have done a lot of work in attempting to understand what exactly it is
如果你想去了解的话，我确实请求你们自己去做研究。我只是觉得在这里谈论它并不是一件积极的事情。但我们在轶事和临床上确实知道，许多人可以克服童年创伤，而不会经历我们刚才谈到的一些影响。有那么多经历过忽视、虐待、父母离异、亲人离世或事故的人，他们并没有走向成瘾，而是过上了非常精彩的生活。并且在经历创伤后，我们确实知道有些人往往比其他人更容易在成年后取得更好的结果。心理学家做了大量的工作，试图去弄清楚究竟是什么原因
about that individual that might make someone more primed or likely to be able to overcome an event versus people who, you know, might actually experience some of those long-term impacts that can be associated with childhood trauma. None of these, as we said, are always going to occur. You know, if you've experienced, you know, your parents getting divorced, if you had a chronic illness when you were a child, if you happen to experience sexual or physical abuse, you know, abuse, it's not, you know, it's not determined that you're going to end up, you know, with severe depression. And understanding what kind of protective factors there are is really crucial. So what are some of these determinants for more positive outcomes in the wake and in the face of
让某个人与其他人有所不同，这可能会使某人更有准备或更有可能克服某个事件，而另一些人实际上可能会经历与童年创伤相关的长期影响。正如我们所说，这些情况并非一定会发生。你知道的，如果你经历了父母离异，如果你在童年时患有慢性疾病，如果你不幸遭受了性虐待或身体虐待，你知道的，虐待并不能注定你最终会患上严重的抑郁症。理解存在什么样的保护性因素真的是至关重要的。那么，在面对童年创伤或复合型创伤时，
traumatic or complex trauma from childhood? Okay, trauma is going to impact people differently based on a number of factors. children, even at birth, are not blank slates. They are born with a certain neurological makeup and a temperament. And as these children get older, these differences become greater as they're impacted by the experiences and their environment. But there are some children and some people who have greater resilience, have a temperament that is more passive or more active
能够带来更积极结果的决定因素有哪些呢？好吧，创伤对不同的人会产生不同的影响，这取决于许多因素。孩子们，甚至在出生时，都不是一张白纸。他们生来就带有某种神经系统构成和气质。随着这些孩子的长大，由于受到经历和环境的影响，这些差异会变得越来越大。但有些孩子和有些人表现出更大的韧性，他们拥有更温和或更积极的气质，
and might be overcome experiences that they, witness or that they're privy to. Cultural groups as well really impact our development and they impact on our experiences and our opportunities. Cultural groups are likely to have particular values and priorities and practices and child rearing that's going to impact how a child might respond following a traumatic event. And these factors all interact to make individuals more susceptible to the long-term impacts of trauma. And this is obviously a really complicated interaction. but some researchers put together a number of factors that they identified might determine whether someone who's experienced trauma as a child is going to have more adverse versus more
并且可能会克服他们目睹的或他们所了解到的经历。文化群体也确实极大地影响了我们的发展，它们影响着我们的经历和机会。文化群体往往具有特定的价值观、优先事项、育儿实践和习俗，这些都将影响孩子在遭遇创伤事件后的反应方式。所有这些因素相互作用，使个人更容易受到创伤长期影响的影响。这显然是一个非常复杂的相互作用，但一些研究人员总结了许多因素，他们认为这些因素可以决定一个在童年时期经历过创伤的人究竟会有更多的不良体验，还是会有更多的
positive experiences. And there are also kind of a list of factors that clinical psychologists and even the average person can use to measure the impact of their trauma, although I think subjective experiences and your experience of trauma is probably the best indicator. So number one is how serious was the event. I just want to say really quickly, severity is subjective, but it really matters how serious the event was objectively. You know, were you seriously physically hurt?
积极的体验。同时，这也有一系列的因素可供临床心理学家甚至普通人用来衡量他们所受创伤的影响，尽管我认为主观体验和你的创伤经历可能是最好的指标。所以第一点是，事件有多严重？我想非常简短地说明一下，严重程度是主观的，但事件在客观上究竟有多严重真的很重要。你知道的，你受过严重的身体伤害吗？
Was your life in danger? Did you lose a loved one? Depending on your developmental stage and the traumatic events impact on your daily life, the effects could really vary. But for some people, something that might be minor to others, could be really serious. So that's important to keep in mind. how close was that trauma to you?
你的生命处于危险之中吗？你失去了挚爱的人吗？根据你的发展阶段以及创伤事件对你日常生活的影响，其后果可能会有很大差异。但对某些人来说，在别人看来微不足道的事情，可能会非常严重。所以这一点需要牢记在心。创伤距离你有多近？
Trauma can impact people who aren't even close to us. You know, we might experience, you know, the death of someone at our school when we were a child. You might not have been close to that person. It's still going to be really traumatic, but often the closer you are, the more significant the impact the trauma has. Whether you were a victim or a witness
创伤甚至会影响那些与我们并不亲近的人。你知道的，在我们小时候，我们可能会经历学校里某人的离世。你可能并不了解那个人。这仍然会非常具有创伤性，但通常你与受影响者的关系越近，创伤产生的影响就越显着。你是受害者、目击者，
or it's something that you learned about determines how severe an effect the trauma has on you. you know, trauma with caregivers is going to be a lot more impactful than a trauma in your community. You know, your caregiver, your parent, that person is, you know, directly responsible for your safety and your well-being. So if they pass away or if you, you know, unfortunately experience abuse from that person, that's going to impact you a lot differently. how did your caregiver or your community react to the trauma? So feeling understood by your parents or your caregivers provides feelings of trust and attunement. And attunement can really help you feel accepted and loved and better prepared to cope with your trauma.
还是从别处听说这件事，决定了创伤对你影响的严重程度。你知道的，来自照顾者的创伤要比社区中的创伤更具冲击力。你知道的，你的照顾者、你的父母，这个人直接对你的安全和福祉负责。所以如果他们去世了，或者如果不幸的是你遭到了这个人的虐待，那将对你产生截然不同的影响。你的照顾者或社区对创伤作出了怎样的反应？感受到来自父母或照顾者的理解能够带来信任感和同频共振感。而这种共鸣真的可以帮助你感受到接纳和爱，并让你做好更好的准备来应对创伤。
You know, if you've got a parent who is there for you and who loves you and who gives you unconditional love and support and, you know, a sense of trust and that you can feel vulnerable, I think you're going to be a lot more protected than if you didn't have that support structure in place. Were there previous traumas, people experience many types of trauma throughout their lives. We summarised a whole list earlier. Suppose you already have a history of traumatic events occurring in your home life, or you've had a buildup of those minor traumas we talked about, experiencing food insecurity or housing insecurity or poverty. In that case, it could actually impact or amplify what, you know,
你知道的，如果你有一个父母一直在你身边，爱你，给你无条件的爱与支持，并带给你信任感、让你觉得可以展露脆弱，我认为你会比那些没有这种支持结构的人受到更好的保护。以前是否经历过创伤？人们一生中会经历多种类型的创伤。我们前面总结了完整的一大串。假设你的家庭生活中已经有了创伤事件的历史，或者你经历了我们刚才谈到的那些微小创伤的积累，例如经历粮食不安稳、住房不安稳或贫困。在这种情况下，它实际上可能会影响或放大，
it can actually amplify the impact that the trauma has on you. So if you are an individual who grew up in a really loving home and who had everything provided for them and who never had to worry and then you've had this one singular event versus someone who has experienced poverty, experienced abuse, experienced neglect, experienced bullying, and then a really traumatic event happens, it's a really complex interaction about which of those two individuals, the outcomes are going to be worse for.
它实际上会放大创伤对你产生的影响。所以，如果你是一个在一个充满爱的家庭中长大、拥有一切提供给他们、从不需要担心的个人，并且你只经历了这单一的一起事件；相比之下，另一个人经历过贫困、虐待、忽视、霸凌，然后又发生了一次真正具有创伤性的事件，那么这两个人中到底哪一个的结局会更糟糕，这是一个非常复杂的相互作用。
And in some situations, people might say that the person has experienced a lot of trauma in the past and a lot of minor built-up accumulated traumas might actually be better placed because they have coping mechanisms, maybe not positive ones, maybe they experienced association, but they do have something that can get them through, whereas someone who has never experienced anything like that is going to be completely shocked and unsure about where to go from there. Another factor is if there were support or backlash from your community. Our community and our social identities impact us in so many ways.
在某些情况下，人们可能会说，这个人过去经历过很多创伤，许多轻微的、日积月累的创伤实际上可能让他们处于更有利的位置，因为他们拥有应对机制——也许不是积极的，也许他们经历过解离，但他们确实拥有某种能让他们挺过难关的东西，而一个从未经历过类似事情的人将会完全震惊，并且不知道从何处着手。另一个因素是你的社区是否提供了支持或产生了反对。我们的社区和我们的社会认同在许多方面影响着我们。
It is the building block of our self-concept. So whether that is your local community or your religious group that you might be a part of or people in the same school as you or people who are of the same. race or ethnicity of you as you, those around you can respond differently to traumatic events. And having a supportive community can positively impact a child and reduce the long-term risks of childhood trauma. There's also other factors like resilience. People who are more resilient are able to overcome these experiences by applying a helpful understanding of the event rather than a negative perspective that can centre on shame and self-blame. And resilience really does refer to
这是我们自我概念的基石。无论是你的本地社区、你可能参与的宗教团体、与你在同一所学校的人，还是与你有着相同种族或族裔背景的人，周围的人对创伤事件的反应可能会有所不同。拥有一个支持性的社区可以对孩子产生积极的影响，并降低童年创伤的长期风险。还有其他因素，比如韧性。更有韧性的人能够通过对事件采取有益的理解，而不是聚焦于羞耻和自责的消极视角，来克服这些经历。韧性确实是指
your ability to bounce back. So it makes sense why people who are high in the characteristic of resilience might find it easier. And following a traumatic event, research is also revealed two other really crucial factors. And they kind of tend to separate those who might now suffer a disorder as a result of their experience versus those who never developed things like anxiety or depression or PTSD or those who have recovered from those experiences. These factors are mastery and social support. Mastery refers to the degree to which individuals perceive themselves of having control and influence over their life circumstances. This is not the same as optimism. You know, optimism being like, oh, everything's going to turn out, you know, outright for me.
你重新振作起来的能力。因此，为什么具有高韧性特质的人会觉得这更容易，也就说得通了。在经历创伤事件后，研究还揭示了另外两个极其关键的因素。它们往往能够区分出那些因经历而现在患上某种障碍的人，以及那些从未发展出焦虑、抑郁或创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的人，或者是那些已经从这些经历中恢复过来的人。这两个因素就是自主掌控感（mastery）和社会支持。自主掌控感是指个人认为自己对生活环境有多大控制权和影响力的程度。这与乐观主义不同。你知道的，乐观主义就像是“哦，一切都会对我有好结果的，
I'm optimistic about the future. No, no, it's about whether you believe that you actually can change things in your life, whether you actually are in control of what you experience. So if you are someone who has experienced childhood trauma, but you are so certain and you have that high level of mastery that things are in my control, I can leave this situation, I can pursue a better life, I can make something better for myself, I can raise my children in a different way to how I was raised versus someone who thinks, you know, everything is determined for me, I can never escape, I can never leave, I have no control. We can kind of see how the impacts and the result of a traumatic event might differ. And the second factor which we talked about
我对未来很乐观”。不，不，这关乎你是否相信自己实际上可以改变生活中的事情，是否真正掌控了你的经历。所以，如果你是一个经历过童年创伤的人，但你非常坚定，并且拥有高度的掌控感，认为事情在我的控制之下，我可以离开这种境地，我可以追求更好的生活，我可以为自己创造更好的东西，我可以用与自己成长方式不同的方式抚养我的孩子；而相比之下，另一个人认为“一切都是注定好的，我永远无法逃脱，我永远无法离开，我毫无控制力”。我们就能看出，创伤事件的影响和结果可能会有多么不同。第二个因素是我们刚才谈到的
a little bit earlier, but I do want to stress again is social support. It is just one of the biggest, biggest protective factors. You know, if you have supportive social ties, if you're friends, if you have friends and family who love you, maybe you have a mentor or extended family who looks after you who make sure you're okay, you are a lot less likely to develop some of those disorders and more likely to recover from an event than if you didn't have them. And in contrast, unsupportive and unreceptive and critical responses from your family, from your community, from your friends, that puts you at risk of PTSD and of things like dissociative disorders or depression and anxiety. And I think the research is something they really stated and they wanted
稍微早一点，但我还是要再次强调，那就是社会支持。它是最大、最重要的保护因素之一。你知道的，如果你有支持性的社交关系，如果你有爱你的朋友和家人，也许你有一位导师或照顾你的大家庭成员，他们确保你一切安好，那么与没有这些支持的人相比，你患上某些障碍的可能性要小得多，并且从事件中恢复过来的可能性要大得多。相比之下，来自家庭、社区和朋友的不支持、不接受以及批判性的回应，会让你面临患上创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、解离性障碍、抑郁症和焦虑症的风险。我认为研究确实非常明确地指出了这一点，他们希望
to explain why this might be the case. And it's because it likely a risk. rises from attempts to discourage open communication and attempts from your community or to not listen to you, to not be responsive to what you're saying. And that increases cognitive avoidance within you and suppression of trauma-related memories and social withdrawal and self-blame. If you don't feel like you have an environment or a place where you can openly and freely talk about what you've been through in a way that you're allowed to process your trauma, but also you're allowed to share, what's going to happen is you're going to kind of suppress that. And you're going to push it down and, you know, kind of learn that no one wants, no one cares. No one wants to
解释为什么会这样。这是因为风险很可能源于试图阻止公开沟通，以及你的社区试图不听你倾听、对你所说的话不予回应。这会增加你内心的认知回避、对创伤相关记忆的压抑、社交退缩以及自我责备。如果你觉得没有一个环境或地方可以让你公开、自由地谈论你的经历，让你既能处理创伤，又能倾诉出来，那么会发生的事情就是你会压抑这种感觉。你会把它压下去，然后，你知道的，学会没有人想要、没有人关心。没有人想要
know about this. And that can really create a lot of adverse experiences and maybe put you at more at risk of, you know, substance abuse and depression like we've talked about. We've talked so much in this episode about the origins of trauma. We've talked so much about what might protect you, so much about where trauma can come from and why it is so impactful if you are a child and especially if trauma occurs in close family environment or within your family unit. But there's hope. There's always so much hope if you are someone who has experienced this and you're looking to this episode for encouragement and healing like we talked about at the beginning, I really want to talk about some of the options for treatment or the options for
了解这些。这确实会产生很多不良体验，并且可能让你面临更高风险的物质滥用和抑郁，正如我们所讨论的那样。我们在本期节目中谈论了太多关于创伤的根源。我们谈论了太多关于什么可以保护你，谈论了太多关于创伤可能来自哪里，以及为什么它对儿童如此具有冲击力，特别是如果创伤发生在亲密的家庭环境或你的家庭单位内。但还有希望。如果你是一个经历过这一切的人，并且正指望这期节目来获得鼓励和治愈，正如我们在开头所谈到的那样，永远都有这么多的希望，我真的很想谈谈一些治疗的选择，或者
getting help. And the ones that I think are recommended by professionals. But as always, if this is something that you are considering, I do suggest going, getting a mental health care plan if you're in Australia or going to your doctor or a psychologist anywhere you are in the world and talking to them about it. Some of the things they might recommend are things like cognitive behavioral therapy. So this focuses on the relationship between your feelings and your thoughts and your behaviours and it kind of targets problems and symptoms and focuses on changing your patterns of behaviour that could lead to difficulties in functioning so maybe if we think about the drug addiction or substance use challenge here
寻求帮助的选择。以及我认为专业人士推荐的那些方法。但和往常一样，如果你正在考虑这些，我确实建议你去制定一个心理健康护理计划（如果你在澳大利亚），或者去你所在世界的任何地方找你的医生或心理学家，和他们谈谈。他们可能会推荐的一些事情包括认知行为疗法（CBT）。因此，这侧重于你的感受、想法和行为之间的关系，它针对问题和症状，侧重于改变可能导致功能受损的行为模式，所以也许如果我们在这里考虑毒品成瘾或物质滥用的挑战，
if you are someone who when you experience a flashback or when you experience you know you're triggered because of a traumatic event you went through in childhood you might immediately go to suppress that using alcohol and cogger. behavioral therapy tries to make us understand that we can actually choose a different behavior. And that might lead to better outcomes for us. There's also prolonged exposure. So this is actually a typical, it's kind of a, not a typical, but a very specific, maybe niche type of cognitive behavioral therapy. And it teaches us to gradually approach trauma-related memories and feelings and situations.
如果你是一个在经历闪回时，或者当你经历由于童年经历的创伤事件而被触发时，你可能会立即去使用酒精和认知来压抑它。行为疗法试图让我们明白，我们其实可以选择一种不同的行为。这可能会为我们带来更好的结果。还有暴露疗法（prolonged exposure）。实际上，这是一种典型的方法，它算是一种——不是典型，而是一种非常具体、也许是小众类型的认知行为疗法。它教导我们逐渐接近与创伤相关的记忆、感受和情境。
And whilst we're approaching them to also apply. meditative or mindful practices so we can lower our sense of anxiousness and arousal. Often when we are triggered by something, we're put straight back into that experience. So our bodies and our brains are flooded with those same kind of neurochemicals and feelings and emotions that we originally felt during that first event. So what prolonged exposure wants to teach us to do is to instead of avoid that because we're worried that we're going to be, you know, overwhelmed and we're worried we're going to panic or be distressed. It teaches us that when we are exposed to a triggering memory or a triggering
并且在接近它们的同时，也要应用冥想或正念练习，这样我们就能降低我们的焦虑感和唤醒度。通常，当我们被某事触发时，我们会直接被拉回那段经历中。因此，我们的身体和大脑会被那些我们在最初事件中感受到的相同的神经化学物质、感觉和情绪所淹没。所以，暴露疗法想要教导我们做的是，不要去回避它，因为我们担心自己会被压垮，担心自己会恐慌或痛苦。它教导我们，当我们暴露在触发记忆或触发
thought, that those cues are not dangerous and you're not in any danger anymore. You don't need to avoid those situations. It teaches us to have a positive experience or a positive mental reaction to those triggers. It's been really effective for a lot of people. It's not offered by many places, but there is so much evidence suggesting it's a really great way to move on from trauma. There's also medication. I'm not going to talk about that so much, but things like SSRIs, it's not so much for treating PTSD, but more for treating some of those other conditions that might arise from a traumatic event, like depression and anxiety. And finally, creating a safe environment, creating an environment where you feel like you are able to process your trauma and
想法中时，这些线索其实并不危险，你已经不再处于任何危险之中了。你不需要回避这些情况。它教导我们对这些触发因素产生积极的体验或积极的心理反应。这对很多人来说都非常有效。虽然很多地方并不提供这种疗法，但有大量的证据表明，这是摆脱创伤的一个非常棒的方法。还有药物治疗。我不会过多谈论这个，但像选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂（SSRI）这类药物，与其说是用于治疗创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），不如说是用于治疗由创伤事件引起的其他一些状况，比如抑郁和焦虑。最后，创造一个安全的环境，创造一个让你觉得自己有能力处理创伤的
you are able to feel safe in a way that maybe you didn't get to feel. I think that's one of the most amazing things that I see happening is people who have understood how their parents and their grandparents and their family have been impacted by events in the past and this trauma has been passed down and these reactions and these responses and these behaviours have been passed down and they're breaking that cycle of intergenerational trauma by healing their inner child by creating spaces where they feel seen and heard by having room for creativity and exploration and love. Trauma is really, really hard. It's really difficult, especially when we are children.
环境，并且让你能够以一种你以前可能从未感受过的方式感到安全。我认为我看到的最奇妙的事情之一就是，那些了解了他们的父母、祖父母和家庭是如何受到过去事件影响的人，他们明白这种创伤是如何代代相传的，这些反应和行为是如何被传递下来的，他们正在通过治愈自己的内在于儿童、通过创造一个让他们感到被看见和被听到的空间、通过为创造力、探索和爱留出空间，来打破代际创伤的循环。创伤真的非常非常难。它真的很困难，特别是当我们还是孩子的时候。
You know, we are so receptive to everything in our environment. You know, as kids, we're just trying to learn. And if those learning experiences we're presented with are ones that are really difficult and ones that are based in violence or abuse or loss or abandonment, It can really impact who we become as adults, but I want to say that in no way means that your destiny is secure and that your destiny is kind of solidified. You have the option to change that path and so many people anecdotally and clinically who have experienced really immense trauma go on to lead incredible, incredible lives. And most people will experience a traumatic event in their life, but the brain is so flexible. and great at bouncing back.
你知道的，我们对环境中的一切都极其敏感。你知道的，作为孩子，我们只是在努力学习。而如果我们所接触到的那些学习经验是非常困难的，并且是建立在暴力、虐待、失去或抛弃的基础上的，它确实会影响我们成年后成为什么样的人，但我想说，这绝不意味着你的命运已经注定，你的命运已经一成不变。你有选择改变这条道路的权利，而且许多在轶事和临床上经历过巨大创伤的人，依然继续过着难以置信的、精彩绝伦的生活。大多数人在生活中都会经历一次创伤事件，但大脑具有极强的韧性和恢复力。
And when you are able to surround yourself with supportive people, when you are able to pursue wellness and happiness for yourself, receive support from a psychologist or someone who can help you process your triggers and process your thoughts around what has happened to you, there is no reason why you cannot live a life just as wonderful and lovely and full of love as someone who may not have gone through that. So I do really hope that with all that we've talked about today, we are able to collectively recognize that there is hope for the future.
当你能够让自己身边环绕着支持你的人，当你能够为自己追求健康和幸福，从心理学家或能够帮助你处理触发因素以及处理关于发生在你身上的事情的想法的人那里获得支持时，没有任何理由说明你不能过上和那些可能没有经历过这些的人一样精彩、可爱且充满爱的生活。所以我真的希望，通过我们今天讨论的所有内容，我们能够共同认识到未来充满希望。
And then if you are someone who has experienced trauma as a child, first of all, I'm so proud of you for listening to this episode. And I'm proud of you for getting through that. And I just can see amazing things in your future. You're going to do amazing things. You're on the right track. You know, you're listening to this episode. So, yeah, proud of you.
如果你是一个在童年时期经历过创伤的人，首先，我为你收听这期节目感到无比骄傲。我为你能够挺过来感到骄傲。我能看到你未来有无限的可能。你会做出非常了不起的事情。你正走在正确的轨道上。你知道的，你正在收听这期节目。所以，是的，我为你感到骄傲。
And thank you for listening. Thank you for, yeah, tuning into this new episode. It was a long episode, so I appreciate it if you've made it this far. But I also think it was such an important one and one that I've wanted to do for a while. Like I said, we could not cover everything. It's such a vast, vast topic. But I hope that we covered the basics and that you learn something. And if you did like this episode, please feel free to subscribe to the show wherever you're listening right now.
谢谢你的收听。谢谢你，是的，收听这期新节目。这是一期很长的节目，所以如果你能听到这里，我非常感激。但我也认为这是一期非常重要的节目，也是我一直想做的一期节目。正如我所说，我们无法涵盖所有内容。这是一个极其庞大、极其广泛的话题。但我希望我们涵盖了基础知识，并且你学到了一些东西。如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在你现在收听的任何地方订阅这个节目。
And leave a five-star review on Spotify, Apple, Apple, podcast, wherever you get your podcasts. It really helps the show to grow. And you know, it's just me doing this. So it really makes my day when I see that people really like what I'm doing or send me lovely messages. It's just so heartwarming. And thank you, as always, for listening. We will be back next week with a new episode. Have a lovely day. On the Look Back at a podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode,
并在 Spotify、Apple、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方留下五星评价。这真的对节目的成长很有帮助。而且你知道的，这只有我一个人在做。所以当我看到人们真的很喜欢我正在做的事情，或者给我发来可爱的消息时，我的一整天都会变得格外美好。这真的太暖心了。一如既往，谢谢你的收听。我们下周将带着新节目回归。祝你有美好的一天。欢迎收听 Look Back at 播客。1979年，对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是 Sam J.，我是 Alex English。每一期节目，
we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何在朋友、同仁喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下挺过来的。就像 Mark Lamont Hill 谈论80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio App 上收听 Look Back At It，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方收听。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kier Gaines。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的、有执照的专业人士对话。有多少男人背负着盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我整个人都惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《困在爱中》（Love Trapped）。“劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。”随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。